we are painters Jackson we don't have
any money we don't get by we struggle
you are a great artist
I believe in Jackson Pollock you're
looking at an oscar-winning performance
that's Marcia Gay Harden she won an
Academy Award for her role as artist Lee
Krasner in the 2000 movie Pollock but
these days you can see her on TV
and they hit CBS medical drama code
black Hardin plays dr. Leanne rorish the
residency director who leads a team in a
busy ER they call her daddy there here's
a preview of tonight's episode any money
idea you know
decreased breath sounds on his left side
bass shows blew it on his left lung
let's get it ready for chest you guys
this is congressman Reese well it
doesn't change the fact that he also has
a dislocated right shoulder let's put it
back in there in the same car daughter
Nerys doesn't have a daughter but they
could play a rhythm Lou dr. Hannah we do
not speculate on a private
mrs. harden shares a personal medical
battle in her new book it's called the
seasons of my mother a memoir of love
family and flowers she talks about her
mother Beverly who is battling
Alzheimer's disease the book is
published by atria that's an imprint of
Simon & Schuster and that's a division
of CBS Marcia Gay Harden we welcome you
to the table okay good morning everyone
hi so I was so touched by your book my
mom died when she was 60 and I was 40 so
I have great envy for people grown-ups
who still have their mother in their
lives and I thought what you wrote about
your mother was so touching with a love
letter to her but it also talked about
your career but you said your mother a
mother is the truest friend you'll have
in your life and I think that's so true
that's absolutely true my mother was my
best friend
that was a Washington Irving quote and
it just we appreciate our mothers all
they do all they give us even when they
get on our nerves the passage of
motherhood but from writing this book
was sort of chronicling the seasons of
my mother and how our lives were
interwoven and I got Alzheimer's you
said it's a disease with no dignity she
maintains her she maintains hers and
that this is a case where you can't make
lemonade out of lemons well you know
that's true people there's no bright
side to this there's a bright side to
Alzheimer's although there is hope
around the corner for drugs but in the
moment there is no bright side and so
you can only repurpose your pain towards
something positive although be in part
because of Alzheimer's you wrote this
book that was the repurposing of the
pain you know it's something positive
what did you discover or was there
something did you discover in the
intentional act of writing that was a
revelation I think it was the
opportunity to reflect on who my mother
was
and therefore Who I am and there was one
passage didn't worry I talked about my
mother's what I assumed was passivity my
mother would always say if you can't say
something nice don't say anything at all
so I thought that was passivity and as I
got older I thought that wasn't
passivity Marcia Gay that's called
reserved sometimes you don't need to
grow your negative opinion out and
correct all the wrongs you should speak
truth to power but sometimes there's a
way of speaking truth to power that has
more diplomacy than criticism in it
that's one thing I definitely learned
from my mother and restraint is a
powerful model strain what about is your
strong point what about when you when
you begin a mother reflecting back on
you know did you have that normal
experience we all have when we become
parents which is oh gosh I guess mom was
right almost every day my mother was
right you can't help but glean so much
from your mother and one of the things I
noticed for my kids is they weren't
getting to get to know my mother they
didn't get to know their grandmother and
so I did not want her legacy to be
Alzheimer's I wanted her legacy to be
this beautiful life that she's lived and
that's really why I wrote it and I will
say that as I wrote it I would read it
aloud to my kids because I'm an actress
so that's how I write how are the words
sounding so they sort of got to know my
mom a bit through me reading about her
you said you were angry that they didn't
get to know the mom that you knew and so
this is sort of helping them get to know
her as well let me talk about your new
show though cuz let's move on to that
you're here for the third season now of
code black what can we expect this
season we were just talking about how
Americans are so fascinated by medical
drama because you're so universal in
every hospital in the world there's
somebody going through the same thing
there's a baby that needs attendance
there's a father who's dying so that
universal urge to have a doctor heal you
is you know we can all relate to it
but in this one the theme is again about
motherhood from my character LeAnn who's
sort of a badass a ER doctor and now she
is trying to attempting to adopt Ariel
so I think there's that's really an ER
situation is raising a teenager in age
right she's that er on both sides of her
yeah you said she gets three eye rolls
but you got a big dance scene coming up
which you did with a broken toe
anyone who's had a broken toe that is
very it's painful you're worried about
how you look with your broken toe as
opposed to that you know yeah that's all
my vanity took over I was like do I have
one chin and does it look okay something
only a woman can get away with right and
you could do it in heels they did it and
if you eyeliner backwards and backwards
right great to have you on set thank you
thank you for being here and the seasons
of my mother is on sale now and you can
also watch Marcia on code black it airs
tonight and
every Wednesday at 10/9 central right
here on CBS